a top commander with the islamic jihad
militant group in gaza has reportedly
been killed in an israeli airstrike
the death of hussam abu harbid comes as
the conflict between israel
and islamist militants rages in the
enclave
the israeli army said harbid was behind
several anti-tank missile terror attacks
against israeli civilians
this included one attack on the first
day of the current round of fighting
that the army said had injured a
civilian in israel prime minister
benjamin netanyahu said
that attacks in gaza are continuing at
full force
and will take time
the aftermath of israel's latest
airstrikes on
gaza residents are left picking through
the rubble that used to be their homes
they say the attacks were the most
ferocious yet
we were certainly scared especially the
children
we feared they would be wounded that
they would die or be buried under the
rubble
israel says it's aiming to destroy
terrorist infrastructure
and is targeting militants the army
later released footage
it says shows strikes killing a senior
palestinian militant commander
israel's jets also targeted an
underground network of tunnels
used by the militants in their early
morning raid
a residential complex in the city of
ashdod hit by a hamas rocket
hamas has kept up its barrage in
southern israel
not all missiles are intercepted by
israel's defenses
as the bombs keep falling the
international community is becoming
increasingly alarmed
denmark the us says it's working to
defuse the situation
the united states remains greatly
concerned
by by the violence by the escalating
violence
hundreds of people killed or injured
including
children being pulled from the rubble
we'll continue to conduct intensive
diplomacy
to bring this current cycle of violence
to an end but as the killing continues
violence fear and loss remain an
everyday experience
for these children in gaza
dw's tanya kramer is covering this story
for you and she joins us now from
jerusalem uh tanya we understand that
gaza has come under heavy bombardment
again what's the latest information you
have for us from the enclave
well on the one hand as we speak that we
had some rocket alerts so incoming fire
from the gaza strip towards southern
communities and cities
in israel but they have also been again
a very heavy night of bombardments in
the gaza strip
and during the day airstrikes i just
talked to some people there
on the phone what is also very
concerning there is now the humanitarian
situation it is a
sealed off enclave for many many years
there are a lot of shortages
anyway but people are saying they're
having now only about three hours of
electricity
um power lines where apparently are not
working out properly
they haven't worked before either but
now they're cut down
again and that also affects uh you know
water and sewage
and and everything else and also there
has been no humanitarian corridor now
this
is the seventh or eighth day soon
of this campaign one week and they need
new supplies to come in as well from the
humanitarian side
uh tanya uh israeli prime minister mr
benjamin netanyahu said yesterday that
the conflict would take
time and will continue at full force
is there the political will to look for
a way out
well at least in the public safe
statements we're hearing uh that the
israeli government and benjamin
netanyahu the prime minister has said
that very clearly again yesterday
they feel they still have the support of
many countries
international communities especially
also from the us to continue the
military campaign
we could assume that also there are
domestic considerations
uh in this equation there's a lot of
pressure here to achieve something with
this campaign not just to
to stop in the middle as some people
here have told me
um to have a decisive victory so to
speak
and to end it once and for all it's not
quite clear what
is meant by this and also the military
has said they want to continue
as long as they can continue to degrade
all the military
military capabilities of hamas and
islamic jihad
now tanya in conclusion calls for
ceasefire
are growing what can you tell us about
any diplomatic efforts that are
underway well it's very hard you know to
get
any solid information at the moment
there are a lot of reports we know the
united nations special envoy in
jerusalem
is in talks that is also the traditional
role
here but also first and foremost egypt
is
usually the mediator here between hamas
and israel
they're well-established channels they
have done this before
and we are expecting them also to
mediate
in this regard in this matter again and
also the us
envoy that was sent here hadi ammar is
also still on the ground so there are a
lot of
different efforts but it's not so
tangible at the moment
when there would be a breakthrough dwsa
tanya akramer reporting tanya thank you
for your
tireless coverage i greatly appreciate
it
i'm joined now by jeremy isajadov he's
israel ambassador
to germany mr ambassador thank you so
much for coming in today
yesterday was one of the deadliest days
since the fighting began what needs to
happen for the bloodshed to end
well basically what should have happened
in the beginning the hamas should not
have attacked israel with now
over 3 000 rockets and this started last
monday with a salvo against jerusalem
and has continued throughout the week
and this has been one of the most
intense attacks on israeli population
centers that we've had
even though they've been previous
exchanges
and so bottom line is what needs to
happen is that this
has to stop and we are doing all in our
power to protect our citizens
to intercept these rockets and to ensure
that these rockets are not only fired
today but also in the coming
months and years now especially in the
past week what has shocked the world
was the civilian casualties in gaza how
would you respond to people calling
israel's operation disproportionate well
first of all i think as i said
that the attack by hamas on israel with
such
a heavy number of rockets and missiles
and again
let's not forget these are embedded in
the palestinian
infrastructure and they are targeting
israeli civilians and cities
i want to also emphasize one thing
virtually in our estimation 20 to 30
percent of the rockets
also fall within gaza and they kill
palestinians
so i think that when people talk about
the situation in gaza first and foremost
they should come to hamas
and say why did you start this horrific
exchange who needed it what are you
trying to achieve is hamas trying
the damage is done isn't it now now the
damage is done
and has to be prevented again what was
hamas trying to do to make peace with
israel
to bring israel into a peace process
which they don't believe in and which
they're trying to undermine
uh to help the palestinian authority who
they're trying also to undermine
it just did not you know have any sense
so i mean
when you ask me today as an israeli
diplomat what is the logic of
of you know this carrying on i asked
what is the logic of it happening in the
first place
and there one must really come in full
force to hamas
and have them explain themselves in that
sense
a couple of days ago the israeli
military attacked a building that
housed um some international media
houses um
al-jazeera and ap i'm going to
quote um an ap statement saying the
world will know
less about what is happening in gaza
because of what happened there
was the real purpose of this airstrike
to prevent international reporting on
what is happening
no to the best of my knowledge no and
everything i can see on television
whether it's on
cnl al jazeera or the other stations on
deutsche weller
i don't think there's any lack of
coverage and we wouldn't do that in
order to stop
coverage we had very clear information
about
the facilities that would have been
serving
hamas in terms of their intelligence
capabilities their cyber
capabilities and also very particular
equipment
and i'm pretty sure that not everyone
realizes the extent to which hamas again
embeds itself
in the civilian population in order to
try and have a human shield so if anyone
should come to
any uh uh complaints here it should be
to hamas
that that what they did was no uh
less of a war crime than fighting and
shooting against israeli civilians
uh in israel now with all of this the
international community is asking for a
ceasefire but prime minister netanyahu
says the fighting will continue until
calm is restored
how far is israel willing to go look
we didn't seek this exchange and
essentially i think you need again
hamas needs to cease the rocket fire on
israel
and until it does israel will not this
is the end defending its citizens
so i mean the question has to be
addressed to them
uh and as far as what i'm concerned i do
not
see this as something that has to be
protracted without end
uh eventually it'll come to a close
there are a lot of different
conversations happening now
what are the conversations there are
conversations between the americans and
israel
we also have very open channels between
the foreign minister of germany who's
speaking to qatar
speaking to egypt and he's also speaking
frequently to
gabi ashkenazi the foreign minister and
i also believe they'll also be very uh
continuing high-level discussions that
will go on in the
coming hours all right we've seen a
flare-up in sectarian
violence in israel over the
past couple of days how worried are you
about the growing rift in your country
first of all i i i i'm worried because i
saw
actually in the last months a growing
desire by the israeli arab community to
be more and more involved in israeli
politics
and you could see this in a range of
things that happened after the last
election and possibilities of coalition
i thought this was an incredibly
important development i think hamas is
very scared of
any type of israeli jewish
arab conciliation so this is a byproduct
of the exchange
which has caused riots in mixed cities
which up till now been a very
major example of coexistence so
i am concerned about it but i believe
living in jerusalem and having
many palestinian and israeli arab
friends that
the ones who are interested in quiet
which are the vast majority of jews and
arabs will want to reassert their right
to live
in peace and in coexistence so
ultimately i
i think that that is what will prevail
right let's talk about the situation
here in germany over the weekend we've
seen
a series of uh pro-palestinian
demonstrations
some of them um saw altercations and
were overshadowed by
anti-semitic rhetoric is the german
government doing enough to curb this
kind of behavior well i think first of
all uh i've spoken
to the some of the initial incidents of
concern where in
north rhine with westphalia i spoke to
amin lashed
the prime minister of the of the state
and he was
very concerned about it and we discussed
and he assured me that they will do all
in their power to prevent it
other senior security officials uh spoke
to me
and also assured me that they will do
all in their power look some of these
uh things of uh fighting against uh you
know jewish communities confronting them
attacking synagogues burning israeli
flags uh these are things
you know it's one thing to have a
peaceful demonstration but another thing
to have these type of acts
which really i mean the jewish community
in germany has
nothing to do with the crisis going on
in gaza and
they are deserving of living like any
other
community in germany in peace and
security and i
um based on what i have heard also from
president steinmeier who spoke out very
loudly against these
attacks also from what i've heard from
horse seahoffer the minister of interior
who came out against these attacks and
he said we will use
all in our power to stop these type of
anti-semitic attacks
so i uh from that point of view i feel
the german authorities will do all they
can to prevent
are you currently concerned about the
security of israelis and jews here in
germany
look i'm always concerned and as i said
i think that these communities should
live quietly and in peace and i must say
i don't want to paint the picture
just negatively we've also had
demonstrations of support and solidarity
from israel
not only from the you know all works of
life in german
in germany but also from even um local
arab leader
arab muslim leaders um and i think
that's important to remember they've
been
support here in leipzig in frankfurt and
even in berlin last friday there was a
meeting with the minister of justice
christina lambrecht with the
minister of culture monica grutas and
also the head of the green party
annalina bierbook
that came to express their support and
to very
much negate any form of anti-semitism
against jews in germany and i and i
think that that is also a very strong
uh sense of uh uh sentiment that i
i feel very uh um at least reassured by
ambassador jeremy aissa thank you very
much for your time today thank you for
having me